hi and welcome to a plug if this is new
to you then my name is Simon and this is
my vlogging project where every week I
talk about my life as an undergraduate
here at the University of Oxford talk
about my work life social life pretty
much everything in between and the point
of which is to try and give you guys an
impression of what it's like to be a
student here from a ground level the way
that these vlogs work is that every week
I have to produce a video which is less
than 5 minutes long and in which I talk
about my work life and my social life
you're very welcome however to leave
suggestions for what you'd like me to
cover in these videos in the comment
section and I will do my very best to
try and fulfill your requests because
ultimately this project is about trying
to help you guys make a decision about
applying to university and give you a
realistic impression of what it's like
to be a student in further tobacco if
you are a user of Twitter or as I like
to refer to you guys as a member of the
Twitterati there's an interesting
project you can follow code box tweet if
you follow hashtag ops tweets there's a
bunch of students from across the
colleges across the years across the
subjects who are tweeting their daily
lives work social life like I'm doing
and they're taking questions from you
guys if you ask their account that's
been left by a guy called Jamie who is a
friend of mine at mortal in college he
also has a YouTube channel doing this
kind of thing
he's vlog the last time I'm really
hoping he's gonna keep working this term
I will link to him in the doobly-doo the
main focus of this term is exams now
exams in Oxford work differently for
Humanities and for the sciences so in
your first year across all the subjects
everybody takes exams called prelims or
mods in some cases and they don't count
towards your degree and then things
split off so for Humanities you don't do
example in a second it and apart from
any dissertations or submitted work the
entirety of your degree is determined by
a couple of weeks of exams at the end of
Trinity term in your third year well for
the sciences including me I'm a
physicist
things are a little bit different so you
take exams in your second year and your
30th and if you're doing it for your
course up in your fourth year in
addition to any work that forms the
basis of your degree which means that
everything's a bit spread out but it
means you have to do exams over you I am
a fourth year soon I'm a finalist which
means that this set of exams is fingers
crossed the last formal set of exams I'm
ever going
take and I cannot begin to tell you how
happy that makes me
term hasn't actually started here but I
like doing these videos to sort of fill
you in on what's been happening between
the terms and to let you know what's
coming up so first of all next week in
fact I have my college bull understand
Peters college and every other year we
host a black-tie ball this year the
theme is the Roaring Twenties so it's
very jazz based it's gonna be really
really cool
I'm also giving a talk at the
university's computing services about
the role of YouTube in Oxford access and
then of course we've got the exams at
the end of the term but I'm not really
thinking about them too much right now
of course after the exams then we also
have the fun stuff which I am thinking
about right now I do have some quite big
news as the type of the video suggests
actually two bits of news so over the
Easter holidays my channel passed a
thousand subscribers and I really wanted
to say explicitly thank you guys so much
it thought was my mind that anybody
wants to watch these videos frankly so I
truly thank you very much for wanting to
take me I want you to see these videos I
really enjoy making them and from the
feedback I've been going with you guys
it seems like you guys find them useful
so thank you thank you thank you the
second bit of news is a quite a bit more
exciting in my opinion because I receive
confirmation over the Easter that I have
a place in Oxford to study for a PhD
next year so I was fortunate to be given
a place working under professor Leslie
gray in the astrophysics department
looking at the link between solar
variability and seasonal forecasting and
it's a PhD which is actually important
partnership with the Met Office what
this means is that for the next three
years provided I get my new one I'll be
able to continue producing theories
about Oxford and about physics generally
so that's ace in my opinion and that's
it for the speaking tom has actually
started yet as I said so there's not too
much to talk about but I wanted to give
you guys a little glimpse into what's
coming up in the meantime however before
next week's sort of the first proper
vlog I give me uploading a series of
videos on the college YouTube channel
that's SPC Oxford where I sat down and
chatted to my colleges formal admissions
represents
if they who's actually paid by the
college to go out there and answer
people's questions about this car stuff
and she's answering questions like how
important are GCC's when applied to
Oxford and what what Sox we're looking
for in a student how important about
cookies activities so I highly recommend
you actually subscribe to the channel
because we've got more content on there
in the future and check out those videos
I will be putting more on this channel
sometime in the next week cheers for
sticking around guys and I will see you
in a week's time for the first look of
term